good evening everybody my name is Syd
Redner I am a faculty member at the
Santa Fe Institute and I'm honored to be
introducing tonight's activities so on
behalf of the Santa Fe Institute I first
want to begin by thanking Thornburg
investment management for their
continuous and generous support of this
lecture series I also want to thank the
Atlantic Performing Arts Centre for the
continued additional support of the SFI
I also want to thank the ushers who
always are very friendly and
accommodating and make it a pleasure to
come into this theater now even though
you've been seeing advertisements flash
by you I've been asked to give two
advertisements even though you've read
them many times so I just want to these
are upcoming events for the Santa Fe
Institute so on October 13th there'll be
a presentation by Jeffrey Ernst off
entitled interplanetary film scores art
craft and science so what goes into
making a great science fiction film
score what are the tricks of the trade
then on October 17th there will be a
panel discussion led by Professor
Manfred la bouche layer who is a
external faculty member of the Santa Fe
Institute and he'll be leading a
discussion entitled the past present and
future of the Anthropocene and here
we're going to be grappling with serious
issues about how do we in a planet of
roughly 10 billion people consuming
prodigiously and emitting prodigiously
how are we going to sustain ourselves so
now let me turn to the main course of
this event which is the second half of a
two-part lecture series under the
auspices of the Stanislaw ulam memorial
lecture presented by professor john
geanakoplos
james tobin professor of economics at
Yale University so yesterday he
presented a number of things that I
thought were very compelling he
presented actually a frightening graph
about the performance of the GDP and how
the economy has taken a two trillion
dollar hit that we haven't yet made up
and how you know why is it that that
happened and he also presented some very
compelling data about the alluring and
pernicious effects of
Everage leverage is great when your
market when your investments are going
up and leverage can really kill you if
your investments are going down and one
of the more serious downsides is when
people get underwater as what happened
in the 2008 crash and there was people
holding mortgages where they owed more
than the house was actually worth and so
professor Jun accomplice was advocating
to restructure the debt to like to lower
the principal payments and in fact the
Huffington Post characterized him as The
Economist that Obama should have
listened to to prevented the crash or to
at least have alleviated the effects of
the crash so this problem of debt
forgiveness is a very tricky issue
because it's somehow at the intersection
between economics and morality and
hopefully we'll learn tonight more about
what we should do about debt forgiveness
well I've heard Sid give many talks and
each time he speaks it's on a completely
different subject I mean he talks about
last when I heard was on figuring out
whether in basketball games the score is
moving randomly or whether you know
things happen in the fourth quarter that
don't happen earlier and listening to
him introduce me I was getting afraid
for a minute there that he was gonna
give my talk but which I'm sure he could
but in any case thank you for the
introduction and I'm glad to be here
again and I'm going to continue from
where I left off except I'm gonna spend
a few minutes reviewing just in case
there are some people here who weren't
here the first time and maybe a little
repetition is a good thing I find that
when I teach my class it actually helps
so bear with me a little bit when I
remind you what happened before so we
said that there are thousands of years
that people have been talking about debt
and lots of wisdom is accumulated we've
created central banks to deal with it
and debts even bigger than ever so if
you look at the ratio of Americans
spending to GDP the blue line is
government spending and you see that
years ago in the 1800s it was extremely
small practically nothing or 20 percent
of GDP
and then after World War two its soared
to a hundred twenty percent then we paid
it down incredibly quickly thirty years
the greatest generation they fought the
war and they paid the debt down that's
why they're the greatest generation now
it's interesting that in those thirty
years as they were paying it down only
twice in 1948 in 1949 did they pay more
than three and a half percent of GDP on
paying the debt down so it was gradual
and it relied on a growing economy it
wasn't just they suddenly decided to pay
the debt down all by themselves but
still the name fits the greatest
generation now since then since they
retired debts been soaring again and so
you see how high it's gotten so the
problem of debt has not only been with
us for thousands of years but it's more
with us than ever now as Sid we're
reminded you I put a picture last time
about of the growth in GDP and we saw
that there was a tremendous dip during
the Great Crash of 2007 trillion dollars
was lost instead of a trillion dollars
gained and since then we've been two
trillion dollars behind where we might
have been had we had the curve kept
going so we've accumulated quite a loss
by now going something ten trillion
dollar or something like that
a massive loss that could have been put
to better use so it's high time that we
tried to avoid something like that again
and rethink a little bit our central
bank policy now of course many people
are thinking about this and policy is
changing and of all the theory I'm
presenting is something that I thought
of before the crisis I'm sticking with
it and I think there are a lot of people
who have similar thoughts nowadays so I
think it's a that's a good sign so I'm
optimistic about the future so we said
that the old consensus the old macro
consensus which is still the consensus
of the newspapers is that the interest
rate is everything that you know the job
of the central bank is to raise interest
rates or lower interest rates to slow
down the economy or speed it up the
trouble with that very first
you might think of is what does it mean
to say credit conditions are tight it
can't be that business people think the
interest rates too high or too low when
they say that they mean that they can't
get a loan at the going interest rate
when credit conditions are too tight
because the lenders are afraid that they
might default so default is the thing
that was missing in the original
tradition so we I described last time
how lenders were being sensible are
going to try and impose constraints on
the borrowers they'll say if you really
want to borrow for this interest rate
you're going to have to have a
respectable LTV a respectable FICO score
those are the two most important things
what's the loan to value in with respect
to the collateral and how good a credit
rating do you have I'll describe that a
little bit more in detail so this is
common sense and Shakespeare knew about
it you know four hundred years ago
so did others we told lots of stories of
people who understood that credit
conditions might be even more important
than the interest rate and the idea was
that when credit conditions get looser
people can buy more they can get the
money to buy more and demand more so the
prices go up and when credit conditions
get tighter it's hard to find the money
to buy and the prices go down
now one subtlety I didn't mention last
time which i think is interesting is
that logic suggests that the looser and
looser credit conditions get the higher
and higher the price is gonna are going
to be so it suggests that if you get to
the the ideal situation the arrow
situation I described a little bit at
the end of the last lecture where you
can borrow whatever you want everybody
trusts everybody and you're able to buy
of course you they're expected to pay
back but everyone trusts you they don't
ask for collateral they don't check your
credit rating they just assume you're
gonna pay back so you can borrow even
more you'd think that by the previous
logic the prices would get even higher
and that this lack of trust
just depresses the economy and squeezes
things down and maybe when things get
loose we're going back to the ideal and
when things get tight we get squeezed
more and the ideals always way above us
but actually that's that's not right so
the interesting thing
is that the prices can be much higher
than they would be in the idealized
world and I think I've skipped a few
slides but I'll finish with this thought
so the reason they could be much higher
than they would be in the idealized
world is because if housing say is the
only thing that you can use as
collateral that means it's the only
thing that you can use to borrow so that
gives it a collateral value an extra
value beyond what it would have in a
narrow debreu world in a narrow world in
the idealized world
you don't need houses to borrow you can
just go borrow but in a world where you
need collateral and only a very few
things or collateral they get an extra
value not only that but suppose you want
to bet suppose that a house is worth a
hundred and you think it's gonna go to
120 although you know what might go to
80 but you're optimistic you think it's
gonna go to a hundred if you buy your
house and sell it front of 20 you've
paid a hundred and you've made twenty
percent profit when it goes to 120 but
if you put twenty dollars down and you
borrow eighty and then it goes to 120
you end up paying back the 80 leaving
you with 40 you've made a hundred
percent profit in fact if you could
leverage five to one like that you could
buy five houses and that's what some
flippers do and you could end up selling
you know all five of them at 120 and
make a hundred dollars or lose a hundred
dollars of things go in the other way so
if you want a bet
buying houses which can be leveraged you
can borrow
when you buy them it gives you an
ability to bet that you wouldn't have
otherwise now in the idealized world you
can bet without having the house so this
collateral value that the few things
that are good collateral have makes a
tremendous gives a tremendous boost to
the price so the prices can be much
higher than the idealized prices would
be even though the only way people can
buy these things is to borrow and you
think that more borrowing the ability to
borrow more would push the price even
higher it's not true if it's one of the
only things that you can use to
it's price is already higher than it
would be in an idealized world so that's
what gives the possibility of things
gain way too high and then getting way
too low so so here's the picture we
showed last time of housing prices this
just Schiller's famous diagram housing
prices in green rising from 2000 up to
2006 the second quarter or something of
2006 ninety percent and six years seven
years incredible increase and then
precipitously falling and the next to it
is the loaned value at least this is not
extreme cases of loan-to-value these are
half the loans non-government loans and
I look at half those people the top half
so basically a quarter of the borrower's
and what's their average LTV so this is
a deal a lot of people could get and you
see that it tracks pretty much with the
prices of housing the the LTV tracks the
housing price it predicts it pretty well
it explains that you might say pretty
well now let's see how interest rates
would have done remember houses started
a hundred in this diagram on the right
in two thousand and go to one hundred
ninety in the second quarter of 2006 so
from 2000 to 2006 straight up and then
sort of a hover little then straight
down let's look at the interest rates
now these are the yield curves so the
yield curve is the most famous object in
finance and maybe in macroeconomics
that's the thing the Fed tries to
control what's the interest rate at the
short end and they can pretty much
determine that and they try to influence
the interest rate at the long end
although not that good it's difficult to
affect that but they they can do that
too
so let's just see what was happening
with the interest rate can I oh how do I
there's no pointer here um I suppose
that I'm supposed to use my finger or no
I don't see the pointer well here it is
come out of nowhere okay so on the right
you see the year this is tooth
that's mm mm okay so the interest rates
are six percent at the short end then
they drop to the green I'm obviously not
going to be good at this they drop in
the green and sorry they're too here
they are in 2000 then remember there was
though there was the crash of the
internet stocks and things like that so
a greenspan does not decided he was
going to lower the interest rates so he
lowered them in from 2000 he lowered
them all the way to always I didn't hear
that all the way to here in 2001 so then
next year they went even lower to the
yellow thing and the year after that
they went to the blue one which is at
one starting at one percent so that
lowering the interest rate suggested to
some people that maybe the interest
rates were starting to make housing
prices go up but then what happened in
2004 well you jump all the way to the
brown thing in 2004 okay and in 2000
this is the thing where it's
two-and-a-half percent then in 2005 at
Trump's to the brown thing that starts
at four percent and in 2006 it jumps to
the green that's starting there at five
percent so the interest rate what went
down for a few years but then the next
three years was going up and it was back
to where it was before and meanwhile the
into the housing prices just kept going
up then what happens after 2006 well it
jumps down now they're they're worried
Bernanke's in control Bernanke's the one
who was raising the interest rates he's
worried that something's going wrong in
the economy so he lowers it to three and
a half percent that's the blue and then
he lowers it in 2008 to the light light
blue which is at the very bottom zero
okay so the interest rates are now at
rock-bottom they stay there for years
that's what's supposed to make every
price go up but the housing prices just
keep going down so clearly this is an
example where the interest rates weren't
controlling the housing prices there you
know the Fed is waving its hands and
going up and down and it's not doing
anything to the path of interest rates
whereas the leverage is so since I got
behind a little bit I'm not going to
talk about something very much
that you might have wanted me to talk
about which is student loans but they're
not very many things you can use to
borrow on except housing maybe cars and
student loans students can borrow by
going to school education is a great
collateral you can borrow a tremendous
amount of money that no one would dream
of letting you borrow if you weren't
going to school so you would expect that
is more and more browing became
available you can leverage your
education the price of education was
going to go up and sure enough it has so
probably that won't come as a surprise
to you a number of years ago actually
there are a number of people who
predicted this but it's it's been a
tremendous increase in tuition and a
tremendous increase in student loans now
I'll come back at the end and talk a
little bit about student loans but
that's one of the punchlines in case
they don't have much time so now that
we've got the idea of leverage raising
asset prices and lowering it and FICO
too
the question is what drives FICO and
leverage we'll fight those a little bit
like when they measure FICO they're
trying it's a combination of they're
trying to determine what kind of person
you are
what kind of proclivity to default you
have have you defaulted before and
they're also trying to look at your
financial situation to see you know
whether you've got the means to whether
you're hugely in debt in other things
then you're probably risk to borrow
still more money so part of it is like
the Nietzschean conscience that's been
either seen how what kind of conscience
do you have so I think of it as a
penalty maybe a cut a self-inflicted
penalty you pay if you default the
higher the penalty the less like you are
to default so of course as conditions
get better the reasons for you to
default get lower so the same person the
same FICO score lenders gonna be more
likely to lend when the when the economy
is doing better because that person is
less likely to get into trouble
so of course credit conditions in FICO
are gonna get better when the economy
gets better secondly about leverage well
it's pretty obvious that as the world
gets more dangerous lenders are gonna be
less likely to give a lot of loans per
dollar of value that's
being used as collateral so uncertainty
now uncertainties a little bit of a
vague term so volatility just what this
is a technical term but you know how
much does the price of the asset move
how likely is it to go down that sounds
like it ought to be the determining
thing for leverage
so the example we just gave in the
two-state case of the house that can go
up to 120 or down to 80 it creates a
credit surface last time we talked about
or if you put loan-to-value on the
horizontal axis and what's the interest
rate you'll charge on the vertical axis
up until you're promising 80 there's no
risk so the lender the collateral is
going to cover it so the interest rates
going to be more or less the same but as
the promise gets above 80 now there's a
chance in the down state that the loan
won't be repaid and so the interest rate
is going to go up and go up quite
sharply as a matter of fact so a lot of
people are probably going to gather
around this 80 thing where there's now a
risk that's growing a lot of borrowers
will congregate there in the two-state
world they'll all congregate there it's
just a property a mathematical property
of two states you can work out that it's
always no one is going to end up
choosing a higher leverage than that but
of course in a more realistic situation
there will be people choosing higher
than that but anyway in any situation
there'll be a lot of people at 80 so 80
that's determined entirely by the
volatility it's just the relationship
between 120 and 80 how big is the drop
and that's going that's the definition
of volatility so in the two-state world
literally volatility is going to
determine how much leverage there is so
that's sort of a theoretical point if
you just tested empirically you can look
a few days ago I got somebody to plot on
a graph for the commodities market the
implied volatility that you know if
there are options being traded you can
figure out what people think the
volatility of the commodities are and
the margin that they're charging that's
the opposite of the inverse of leverage
how much do you have to put down and you
see as the volatility goes up the
margins go up and then this can be
tested going backwards for you know I
forgot how long we did this for but
let's say six months or something and so
you get the more convincing
demonstration of the same relation
it's not perfect because the world is in
two states but the general idea that is
the world's more volatile leverage is
going to go down our margins are going
to go up that's clearly true and here's
an example of a commodity natural gas
and what the mark you know what the
leverage is okay so that's a crucial
second idea that FICO is controlled sort
of by how good the economy is and
leverage depends on how risky the
economy seems to be well if you look at
the history of ups and downs this is the
Dow Jones Industrial every day you can
see the three most important facts about
prices the first that we're all familiar
with the efficient markets hypothesis is
going up and down seems to happen
randomly the stock went up Tuesday
there's no reason to think it'll go up
Wednesday just seems to happen randomly
the second fact is that these ups and
downs they get bigger and more violent
and then they subside but the big moves
cluster together so it's clustered
volatility if it's very risky yesterday
it's gonna be risky today if the price
is moving around a lot it will continue
to move around for a while the third
thing is that if you look at the dates
these big moves you know the beginning
one is the crash 29:30 the depression
the last one is 2008 it turns out that
things move volatility goes up with bad
news so here I got another the same
picture for the Standard and Poor's 500
and I did it up to yesterday and so you
can see how low volatility is right now
incredibly low now as the number of
questioners pointed out yesterday I just
wanted to confirm that they were right
so volatility has gone way down
so anyway volatility is counter cyclical
so if you look at the VIX that's the
volatility level historically in the
blue line it goes up more or less when
the world's going to hell and so you can
see it's going the opposite and if you
look daily you say did the S&P go down
yesterday and if it did what happened to
volatility if it went up what happened
to volatility and you see that it's it's
inversely related so bad move
moves to the left a bad move in the
stock market gets people jittery and
volatility goes up it's what you'd
expect you know when you I mean if you
go to uh if you're waiting for an
airline I have to take a plane at
midnight tonight if you're waiting for
the plane and someone says you know you
hear it's a delay you're gonna be a lot
more uncertain about what's going to
happen then if soin tells you
everything's going well when you hear
it's a delay you start to get worried
that a lot of things could be a big
delay you know and so that's the way the
world works so the basic idea the
leverage cycle is that if the economy is
improving probably volatility is
declining that means credit you credit
standards or loosening and that gives a
boost to prices which it gives a boost
to the economy and so that improves the
fundamentals everything's looking better
and you go round and around in the
circle but then something can go wrong
because if you go around a few times in
the circle things start to get more
vulnerable and that's the last thing I
want to remind you of and that's what
causes the bust so let's take this
standard example when I think of things
getting worse and get things getting
more volatile I think about waiting for
the airplane so here you see that the
payoff of the asset on the right that
column it can be either one so things
can go up or down okay you're at zero
and things can go up or down and then up
or down again and every household h h
stands for a particular person each h
has a probability of things going up or
down so the higher h those are the
optimistic people think things are
probably going to go up now the payoff
at the end is one a lot of the time and
only if everything goes wrong you go
down twice do you get point two so
that's what I I think of as what
happened in the crisis you know it
wasn't just one event it isn't like we
woke up one day and everyone said off
the world's gone bad it was every week
there was another piece of bad news
another one and another one and another
one so what happens when we get a piece
of bad news if you go down well then
you're closer to the chance of getting a
point two so you're that's bad news but
also
your opinion is now more volatile
because what you think
@d is going to be the average if you're
H of one and point two is going to be
between one and point two so at zero you
could go either up to one or down to
something like point seven so it's not
that big a gap but once you go to two
down it could be one or point two now
it's really volatile so that's what I
have in mind when things start to go bad
people think oh well enough bad things
like this we're gonna have a real
problem our hands
you know Trump says that twelve more
times something really might happen and
so volatility volatility hasn't gone up
to the first 75 Trump isms but anyway so
volatility is volatility is going up as
you get bad news so that's the thing
that I have in mind now
all right let's examine what happens in
this situation suppose that they're a
bunch of people as I said indexed by H
so they're optimist and pessimist and
everybody knows the price of this asset
is gonna be one if you go to up but if
you go to down what will the price be
well if you're somebody who's very
optimistic let's say h equals point 87
you think even if you get two down
you'll probably go up anyway
so you're not gonna change your mind
that much actually you think it's worth
about ninety eight at zero and by the
time you get to down you think it's
worth almost 90 because it's 87 percent
to one plus 13 percent 2.2 which is two
point six or eighty nine point six so
you'll go from 98 to 98 points that's
that's how much you think that's how the
extent of the bad news but the price in
this economy is gonna go from 95 to 69
26 points down nobody no matter what
your H is you're not gonna think things
have gotten that much worse if you're a
very low H you would have thought you're
gonna get 2.2 anyways you haven't
learned anything if you're very
optimistic H you think you're always
gonna get to one so there's no H that
could explain such a big drop but the
economy is gonna drop that far and why
is it well basically it's because
there's not much volatility at the
beginning it means the lenders are gonna
lend a lot of money very few people are
needed to buy all the ass
in fact on the left-hand column just 13%
of the people because they can borrow so
much can hold all the asses so 87 is the
critical marginal buyer her opinion is
the one shaping the price now if things
and she's well aware that things might
go down she's not crazy she's aware
that's a possibility she knows how bad
it could be she just doesn't think it's
gonna happen so if it does happen all
those people who borrowed so much money
remember if you're leveraged but you
have a multiple loss and they've
borrowed a lot these people these tops
13% they're gonna be wiped out entirely
and so once they're wiped out on the
right hand side when you hit down
they're gonna have to be new buyers the
new buyers aren't gonna be as optimistic
not only that but they can't borrow so
much anymore because they're in that
uncertain down state where lenders won't
lend them very much anymore so you need
a lot of them to buy so the marginal
buyer is gonna drop all the way from 87
to 61 so that's why the price fell so
much 87 her opinion was what set the
price originally her opinion to go to
the right the same person she still has
a slightly lower opinion maybe went from
98 to 90 so okay her opinion went down a
little bit but she's no longer relevant
she's been wiped out and the new buyer
is someone much more pessimistic and the
price is gonna reflect his pessimistic
opinion and that's why it fell so much
so that was the basic that was the basic
story last time so bad news causes a
price drop because everyone's opinion
goes down but the leverage buyers and
the ones who lose the most and they're
the ones who they're the buyers they're
the ones who kept the price up and
they're disappearing and now the new
buyers can't borrow very much so the
price has to go really far down so that
is I believe that's the story I told and
that's what happened at ellington
basically and that's the story I told in
2000 that's what I think happened in
2007 so let's see what did happen in
2007 the usual explanation is that
housing was critical and there all these
these mortgage derivatives written on
housing in the whole economy was pyramid
on housing and nobody thought housing
could possibly go down
and they were shocked when it went down
and went down farther than anyone
expected and that's what destroyed the
economy there's a lot of truth to that
but why did housing go down that's the
part that they don't explain
show her explains it by saying the
narrative changed it went up so many
times before people started saying it
can't keep going up it's gonna go down
and then someone else would say really I
better sell my house then and pretty
soon it went down so that also has a lot
of merit but my explanation is that it
was the story I just told so what was
the little piece of bad news now let's
look again at this old picture of the
housing price in 2006 housing prices
stopped going up that's not a remarkable
thing they were going up and up and up
because people were leveraging more and
more and more every year you could put
less down well you can't put less than
zero down there the average down payment
was 2.3 percent we said in the second
quarter of 2006 you couldn't put much
less down than that so housing prices
weren't gonna go up much higher but why
did they start going down something
happened well what happened is you
probably know the way subprime mortgages
work is their pooled together and then
they're cut into pieces so there's the
triple B piece at the bottom so if
anybody defaults that bond holder loses
the money then there's a double B piece
and an A and a triple a and and it well
anyway it doesn't matter if there's a x'
and they so the point is it goes up and
up and the people at the top the AE
class they're protected by the people
below them so there are a lot of people
who wanted to short these subprime
mortgages and you may have seen a movie
The Big Short and these three guys in
particular they wanted to short it so
they persuaded but they couldn't short
it so they persuaded the right
Commission to create a light to get
permission from lots of organizations
they created a derivative called an
index called the the a the CD s indexed
on housing which hadn't been there
before so that was created in 2005 and
it's the different index on each tranche
of the pool so you see in 2005 it's at a
hundred and
then what happens at mm the beginning of
2007 it suddenly the end of 2005 at
state starts the end of 2005 then at the
beginning of 2007 the end of 2006 it
starts to go down the triple P pieces go
down a lot so that was a big shock but
where did that come from why did that
price suddenly go down what was the
thing that was so surprising the little
piece of information that made people
realized the world was worse than they
thought well if you look at subprime
loans and the delinquency rate on all
the subprime loans these went back you
know for a long time it wasn't just
something started in 2005 or something
so every year you can see for if this is
the countrywide vintages
so for each starting year and the bottom
you can see what were the percentage of
people who were delinquent they weren't
paying their loan they hadn't gotten
kicked out of their house yet and so you
can see every year going back way for
farther than this it would it would ask
them Toth to 2% the beginning nobody
would default or you know eventually
more people would default some people
would get thrown out of their houses so
they weren't actively in default so the
this number 2% of people actively in
delinquency I mean actively and
delinquency would always just asymptote
there but then you see that if you look
at the 2005 number that's the yellow
line and you look in 2006 it's gone
above 2% it's already three and a half
percent at the end of 2006 in fact it's
four percent in the 2006 one which is
only a year old here has already gotten
to three percent our people are saying
my god what's happening these borrowers
aren't as reliable as we thought maybe
we've gone we've overstepped our bounds
and given loans to too many people maybe
things are gonna get worse now 3%
delinquency is nothing you know even if
all those people got thrown out of their
houses it would be nothing it's not a
big deal the subprime interest rates are
much higher so that's not much of a loss
but it raised the possibility that
delinquencies much might go much higher
so it meant that the triple B pieces
were much more nervous and so the price
of triple B's went way down that meant
it was very hard to create a new pool
because how would you sell off the
triple-b peace unless you could convince
people that they were safer so what
happened is that the people doing
subprime loans who wanted to create
pools started asking for more collateral
so they could say to the potential
triple B people yes the guy maybe we
have some evidence that things are worse
but these are much better protected than
they were before so that's why that was
the news that was the reaction of the
collateral getting tougher and that's
what happened to the prices that's my
story and I'm sticking with it so okay
so why was it such a calamity it's it's
it's the leverage cycle I think but
they're actually a couple more things
going on which are elaborations of the
leverage cycle one is that there was a
sort of double leverage got higher than
ever before but there was a double
leverage cycle there was leverage going
on at the housing level and leverage
going on at the Securities level and if
the houses failed and of course the
securities fail but if the securities
are failing and you can't do anymore
securities that means the loans won't be
given to new buyers which means the
houses are gonna fail so they this is
they it was a symbiotic the opposite of
symbiotic it was mutually destructive
relationship a double leverage cycle and
then the c.d.s that I just mentioned
that was a that made it possible to
short negatively so once you can short
negatively that puts tremendous pressure
on the other side for things to go on
leverage was going up and up but now you
could short negatively so why is that
and what you know what's the operation
just to think about it if you're very
optimistic you could you know buy a
house and bet that it'll go up or you
could sell the insurance now that
there's CDSs like insurance on the thing
going down so the optimist instead of
buying houses they're selling insurance
so it moves the demand away from from
houses or mortgage securities and then
finally well okay there was also a huge
amount of securitization going on so
financial innovation is just an
elaboration of the leverage cycle this
tranching of things is a more
sophisticated way of leveraging and the
CTS's is an opportunity for the
pessimists to leverage so all that to
get
that elaborated leverage cycle is is the
story all right so that's where we ended
last time now I repeated myself a little
bit too long maybe but it was I hope the
second time around is a little clearer
now what can we do about that what
pieces of information can we gather to
help us do better the next time so the
obvious thing to do so obvious that it's
amazing it hasn't been done before and
it was a lot of trouble to get this data
is is to look at credit surfaces so this
is if you can see on the axes this is
the look it's easier to see there it's
the FICO score where at the bottom it's
800 so it's a good borrower at the
bottom and LTV which is a hundred at the
top and goes down to below 60 at the
bottom so the best borrowers at the
bottom and the worst borrowers at the
top and this is from the year 2006 so
you see the interest rate goes up if you
become a horsepower but it's not going
up that much that's why there are these
people taking out these loans because
the interest rate doesn't go up that
much now these are for Fannie and
Freddie loans the best people in America
middle America you know middle class
America that's what they're designed
who've got great you know who have jobs
and who have incomes they can report and
you know these are the best borrowers
you can find the ones I showed before
the non-government borrowers they're the
dicey er borrowers so this credit
surface if you include those other
people you know would go way up all
right but anyway it's pretty flat in
2006 and then you see that most of the
borrowers who are the borrowers this is
the number of people borrowing in each
of those areas you can see that there's
this congregation at 80% and it's middle
America the 750 - 750
now let's look at it 2009 say if you can
remember this is dramatically steeper
than it was before it's the same picture
the same everything it's just much
steeper and so who's borrowing well
those people in the middle they're still
if you've got an 800 score you can still
borrow but if you're towards the back
there in the middle in the back or
you don't you just can't borrow so it's
you can borrow but it's getting hard to
borrow so this is the point when the Fed
started trying to do all its work and
you know quantitative easing lowering
the interest rates trying to do
something about this in fact they were
buying mortgage securities they wanted
to help the mortgage market but what
happens if you look at 2016 it's not
much different the credit surface and in
fact if you look at who's borrowing that
middle group the ones with the medium
fight goes they still can't borrow but
if you've got a really high FICO now you
can leverage even more than you did
before that's I think why sell and last
time asked a question and said people
are leveraging more now even than they
did in the crisis it's only the people
with the highest FICO pristine people
can now borrow even more easily than
they did in before the crisis but
everybody else is having a hard time so
the efforts of the Fed to make it easier
to get a house have not succeeded now
the story could even be more dramatic
because I took leverage as the ratio of
the loan to the value of the house but
in 2006 the housing prices were greatly
inflated if he took another measure of
leverage one Minsky would have approved
of more the rentals the average rentals
that you could get for houses of that
kind and so you took the ratio of the
loan to the imputed value consistent
with the rentals then of course you're
going to find that the housing prices
are much higher sorry the the housing
prices are sorry the rentals the the
sort of corrected price of the house is
much lower than the actual price and so
the loan is gonna be 120% LTV so the
2006 credit surface is incredibly flat
and goes out to an LTV way above a
hundred by that measure but the other
ones haven't changed at all so that's
what I mean by the credit surface when
the Fed decided that it was going to do
quantitative easing it was going to take
extraordinary measures they just said we
wanted to stimulate the economy they
didn't have to say what part of the
economy they were stimulating everybody
figured they thought they were
stimulating the mortgage market cuz
were balling mortgages but it didn't
have that big in effect on the mortgage
market had some effect as I said as we
saw it had some effect sorry because the
very high LTV for the 800 psychos
there's more those than there were
before but it didn't have that much
effect but look at the effect it had on
corporate up corporate America here's
the credit surface now it's reoriented
so here it's that Minsky ratio debt to
you know income so debt to how much your
earnings are so on the Left its debt is
0-2 twice as much and then it gets
higher and higher as you go to the right
so the small debt is on the left hand
corner and then you can see that the
triple A's and is here and triple B is
at the back so the best borrower is on
the left hand corner and the worst one
is on the type top right hand corner so
you can see these are corporates and so
the interest rate gets higher when you
become a worse credit rating or you're
higher you know the leverage is worse
well let's this is 2005 it's pretty flat
here so what happened in 2011 in the
corporate world was a little further
behind it got much steeper everyone
realized the world was dangerous it was
much harder to borrow but then the Fed
kicked in here's where we are in 2013
you see it's flattened that it didn't
change the mortgage credit service but
it changed the corporate credit surface
and here's 2017 I changed the picture
unfortunately but it's even flatter than
it was in 2013 that was bad anyway I
didn't do this someone else did this so
actually it was I'm not gonna embarrass
nobody say it was but anyway it was a
very prominent investor who got excited
about the idea and they came up with the
data to draw these things let's look at
consumer credit why is the economy
gotten better so consumer credit this is
the same picture as as we had before so
these these are from loan what's it
called
who's the online lender a famous online
Lending Club so Lending Club data
so this is just looking at all the loans
Lending Club has and what the ratings
are and what the interest rates are here
it's 2010 to 2012 then it goes 2013 to
14 and 2015 to 16 he gets dramatically
flatter here you see the top one the
worst one is around 13% and before it
was 18% or something so it's
dramatically flatter so the it's gotten
easier to borrow if you are doing a
consumer loan or if you're a corporation
it's not that much easier to borrow if
you're trying to get a house and so
wouldn't it be nice if the Fed was and
maybe a lot of them are thinking about
this I don't want to say that they
aren't thinking about this but wouldn't
it be nice if they had these pictures in
front of them and that before they made
their policy they had to say we're going
to act in the markets so as to have this
effect on the credit surface of mortgage
borrowers corporate borrowers and
consumer borrowers then you would know
what they were really up to and they
would know what they were really up to
and they wouldn't be sort of just hoping
they'd you'd actually have to they'd be
accountable for what they're doing so I
recommend that they do this and not only
that but I recommend that they choose
policies that affect the right credit
service in the way that they want to so
I think they might even be doing that
but they're not saying it if that's what
they're doing ok so that's my story of
the leverage cycle and why we get into
messes and as I said if you get into a
mess where what's owed is so much above
the value of the collateral you get into
tremendous trouble so once you're
talking about the credit surface the
whole point of the credit surface the
interest rates are going up because of
default so you can't talk about a credit
service unless you acknowledge the
possibility of default most central
banks don't acknowledge default they
can't ignore by charter they can't
acknowledge the possibility of default
they can't hold things and they don't
mark them like a hedge fund does they
don't take a Greek bond and say well the
odds are 50% we're gonna get paid we'll
count it as 50 they hold a Greek bond
it's valued at a hundred degrees and
it's supposed to pay so I say that they
should be marking the things that they
hold
according to like any reasonable
investor would taking into account the
possibility that they could default now
that's very important because if they
mark a bond at 70 say and then the
borrower gets into huge trouble
and then the borrower so underwater that
they're never gonna pay anyway now you
have the possibility of forgiving down
to 70 because by forgiving down to 70
you haven't lost any weren't you already
marked it at 70 so it's not a
thirty-foot you already took the 30
percent loss so you can forgive sin 100
down to 70 without taking an additional
loss and by doing that you might
actually get more money than you would
have otherwise you might be able to mark
it at 75 now so I think that was our
biggest mistake in the crisis there are
a number of them Obama is a remarkable
person but a little bit timid and he you
know he did a package of stimulus
package but it wasn't big enough and
could have been bigger at the beginning
he had the whole country behind him he
could have done almost anything and I
you know the deliberations have been
published with him and his advisors so
it's very clear
they chose the stimulus that they did
they could have asked from war but they
didn't now maybe they were afraid they
couldn't have gotten more but that's
leadership you know they didn't try to
get more
so that was one mistake but I think a
bigger mistake was not forgiving
subprime debt because that's clearly
something he wanted to do but he lied
himself be talked out of it so nothing
was done not a single penny of subprime
debt was forgiven and a huge number of
these subprime borrowers got thrown out
of their houses now what's the logic of
forgiving debt so we have a lot of data
on these subprime guys because so many
of them got thrown out of their houses
so we know what happens when they get
thrown you know 400 billion dollars
worth of subprime borrowers got
defaulted so we know what happens it's
not a conjecture we've got all the facts
the let's take a loan that's a hundred
sixty thousand
and the house is down to a hundred
thousand so if you are a person with a
bad credit rating that's why your
subprime borrower you owe 160 on a house
that's a hundred the world seems to be
going to hell why would you pay a
hundred sixty thousand on a hundred that
you know when the house is only worth a
hundred thousand so you probably won't
so when you stop paying you get thrown
out of your house but it you don't get
thrown out the next day it takes a
couple years in some states and most
states to get thrown out of the house in
that time you don't pay your mortgage
you don't pay your taxes you don't fix
the house and when you leave you
probably take as much as you can out of
the house so the recovery of that
hundred sixty thousand the average
recovery we have a huge amount of data
was twenty three percent thirty five
thousand something like that is what the
lender god if the lender had forgiven a
hundred sixty down to ninety which is
less than the house is worth there's a
good chance the lender might have gotten
his money back so who were these lenders
they were mostly hedge funds and people
like that these are subprime
securitization so it's not you know a
little bank holding them it's
sophisticated hedge fund so as I said
last time seventeen hedge funds got
together and say we own these bonds we
think we can get more money by forgiving
the debt they're not forgiving the debt
we don't have the power to do it we just
own the bonds it's the servicers who are
controlled by the big banks they're the
ones who are responsible for collecting
the money and distributing it to the
bondholders only they know who the
actual identity the people you know who
is who there's privacy so it's only the
servicer who knows who everybody is and
only the servicer has the power to
change the terms of the loan and the
servicer had no incentive to forgive any
of the debt for one thing their fee is
proportional to the principal they cut
the debt in half their fee immediately
gets cut in half they have to go to a
lot of trouble to decide how much to cut
it as I said 160 you should cut to 90 if
you cut 160 to 130 you're not going to
do any good so you have to cut 160 to 9
you have to figure out what the house is
worth you have to send people out there
to look at the house and you know decide
whether the homeowners gonna be able to
pay the 90 even and so that's
that they don't get its it's a job they
didn't expect to do in such great
numbers why should they go to all that
trouble this the big banks who own the
servicers they owned almost all a huge
number of second loans they were afraid
that if they started marking down first
loans then people were going to say well
all those second loans should be marked
to zero if the first loans getting
marked down and they didn't want that to
happen so they had very little incentive
and in fact not a single penny of
subprime loans were forgiven so what did
we do instead what we did instead is the
Obama plan so by the way I I wasn't so
prescient I wrote about this in 2008 and
predicted that there were going to be
these huge losses and that was a
disaster if we didn't forgive subprime
debt wrote about it with a law professor
named Susan cognac and then I testified
in Congress a couple times to this
effect but it was very easy to predict
what was going to happen because I
relied on the market the market was
pricing these bonds and from the price
of the market the the hedge fund
investor bonds you could tell how much
recovery they expected to get out of
these people who were going to
eventually default so I didn't predict
myself the recoveries would be so bad I
just looked at what the market thought
and it came out to be not so the market
wasn't so far off so what happened what
did we do
what was the Obama plan it was to say
okay if you're defaulting if you're if
you can't pay and we see that you're not
paying you call us up and you tell us
you're not paying because you've
suffered a hardship and we'll look into
your case if there's really a problem
you've lost your job other things wrong
like that we will then we will then mark
down the interest not the principle just
the interest we'll cut it down to make
it easier for you to pay because
eventually things are gonna get better
and so you know you'll eventually be
able to pay off the whole thing
well what happened a lot of first of all
it's one that's a moral hazard we're
gonna talk about Morehouse in a second
because in order to get looked at you
have to stop paying so you you got
people to stop paying just so that they
could get access to one of these Obama
plans so once they got their interest
rate marked down these people they
actually paid a few times but look at
the recidivism
so here the
number of months on the horizontal axis
till you and what fraction of people
defaulted again
well turns out that you know 50% of them
by 18 months 70 person you know it
depends on how far they marked the
coupon down but even they marked it down
a lot you got almost 50% of the people
defaulting again it wasn't enough to
mark down the interest because they
still thought to themselves the house is
still only worth a hundred thousand and
I owe 160 what am i doing so my plan at
the time our plan Susan Cognac my plan
our plan was to have the government hire
community bankers so these bankers these
would be local bankers like a New Haven
banker someone who actually worked in a
bank would be or had experience with a
bank and looking at loans would be hired
by the government and told you look at
all these loans to New Haven you figure
out what you can do to change the terms
of the contract to make the most money
for the seller if you think marking down
the loan will make more money for the
lender not the seller the lender if you
think marking down the loan will make
more money you know the principal will
make more money for the lender do that
if you think marking down the interest
will make more money for the lender do
that instead we predict that they're
going to mark down the principal that
was the plan so is there a moral hazard
in that plan we're acting on behalf of
the in a way on behalf of a lender but
you could still say there's you might
think that there's a moral hazard and
people say moral hazard all the time I
think this is uh they think it's morally
reprehensible I was told now this may
not be exactly true and I couldn't quite
find the tape in time but I appeared on
TV a lot in 2008 and 9 advocating this
and in one of those conversations and I
forgot which station they suddenly cut
to this guy who was standing on a floor
trading floor in Chicago and he starts
yelling at me and his name is then telly
says what are you doing trying to mark
downloads for those disgusting people
who borrow too much and who's gonna mark
my loan down why should you mark those
ladies screaming and I thought the guy
was crazy so I just
ignored him but apparently I'd been told
I gave the Tea Party its its platform
because that was one of the first
performances of Santelli ad you know
saying that we shouldn't be forgiving
debt anyway he I guess won that debate
so here's here's here's what I was
advocating you could look at that time
in 2008 at the number of people
depending on the loan-to-value what
fraction of them were defaulting every
month
what new percentage the people who are
still paying what fraction of the people
still paying started the faulting and it
was for the highest for the worst the
highest LTV people if you had a highest
LTV people in your subprime that's the
top line so if you're 160 like I said
that's at the far right your the
percentage of people each month who
defaulted was 9% so you knew that these
people eventually were going to default
so I was advocating forget write down
the principle for people who have kept
paying they're still paying they haven't
done anything wrong wasn't their fault
that housing prices went down and by the
way they've still kept up all their
payments they're just gonna realize
eventually that it's crazy to do it
forgive their debt and you'll make more
money forgives and so who's gonna take
the loss not the government it's not the
government paying it it's those hedge
funds who own the bonds they're the ones
who are going to get the reduced
principal but it's gonna end up being
more than it would have otherwise that
was the suggestion in the argument now
of course some of those people who
you've forgiven the debt may have paid
at all maybe some of those people were
gonna pay a hundred sixty thousand even
though the house was only worth a
hundred thousand so there were potential
losses and I've gone to great trouble to
try to calculate after the fact you know
taking into account all the people you
would have forgiven who would have paid
it all etc and it turns out it doesn't
make so much money for the for the
lenders the economy did eventually but
you don't lose practically anything and
it doesn't take into account what a
boost that would have been to the
housing market not to have all those
people thrown out on the streets so that
that's my story
now if you another way to do this the
sort of more sophisticated way of
forgiving principle was suggested a long
time ago by my colleague Bob Shiller and
he said why not make he invented the
Shiller housing index so he thought of
every possible contract depending on the
housing index he said if all if the
index in your general area goes down
enough according to the Shiller housing
index so you're way under water then you
should have some automatically the
mortgage should be written down a little
bit you know written down so that you
still stay above water so this was an
ingenious way that he thought of a long
time ago the reasonable way of forgiving
principal up front in case a disastrous
thing happens so that's the reason why
college loans should work the same way
if you turn out you know people turn out
to have very poor incomes they should
have to pay less back that's why it's so
much better to have the loan amount
indexed your income than to have a fixed
amount and if it gets to be too high
that should be forgiven too but anyway
that was the plan so now Europe is a
very similar situation and I'm I can't
describe the whole thing because I am
too far behind so I'm gonna stick with
what I know best which is the Greek
crisis so I told you how it happened
that the Minister of Finance euclid
tsakalotos had heard my talk on mortgage
forgiveness that I gave the graduation
talk at Athens economics and Business
School so when he became finance
minister he succeeded this guy named
Yanis varoufakis do you remember had
incredibly tempestuous relations with
the Germans especially and things were
looking really grim for Greece and so
Colossus was a much more mild-mannered
guy maybe too mild-mannered but very
mild-mannered guy and so he thought
things would get off to a different
footing and he asked if I would help out
so I had to take a leave from Yale leave
from my hedge fund everything to try and
help out and I didn't provide much help
just before I went I got an email from
someone who said you may not remember me
my name is Kostas he an accomplice I am
a relative of yours and we met in your
grandfather's house in 1963 and in the
village in the village outside of Sparta
called fail logo and the village has all
read about your do you know your
intentions to save the Greek economy and
we'd like to celebrate the rebirth of
the Greek economy by having a village
dinner with you and so I actually
decided I would look up this guy I
didn't really think I was gonna save the
economy or that they were gonna give me
a village dinner I waited a little while
till it was obvious things weren't going
very well and then I went and I met not
him but his son and we met in the house
that my grandfather had left in 1892 as
a 12 year old to come by himself to
America and the house was still there
and was beautiful I guess I'd seen at
1963 but I hadn't remembered it is an
incredibly beautiful house and in my
family everybody does only one of three
things either they're professors or
they're musicians or they're bad tennis
players so he said I asked him his name
he said I am john geanakoplos I said Wow
I said what do you do and he said I am
tennis champion of Sparta and I said
well what else do you do and he said I
am no musician I sing hip-hop music and
I have 11 million followers on YouTube
and I said my gosh you're a professional
musician he said no no no no he said I
went to graduate school and I got my
degree my PhD in economics at the
University of Athens economics and
business and I worked in the bank of
Greece but it was so depressing I
decided to quit and I moved back to the
village and Sparta and now I sell olives
from the same olive grove fact from the
same trees that your grandfather's
family sold back in the 1890s so that
was a stirring meeting and it made me
feel all the worse that I had done so
badly but so I let me
just remind you of how bad the crisis is
in Greece and what I proposed so it's
bad so it began in 2009 when Papandreou
who who was descended is the son of the
famous is the grandson of two famous
prime ministers and he was born in
America and seemed like a very honest
guy and one of the first things he did
was he said that the previous government
had misled everybody about the debt the
deficit it was really much higher than
people said we talked about at the end
of the last lecture so it was much
higher and as soon as he said that all
the lenders began to panic and they said
my gosh maybe things are much worse
we're not gonna lend to you anymore so
then since he couldn't roll over his
loans Greece got into tremendous trouble
and he asked for a bailout so he went to
the troika to ask for a bailout and that
made things much worse so they decided
so here here by the way his interest
rates in Greece and you can see when the
crisis started when people realized the
bailout wasn't working the interest rate
soared and they've been getting closer
and closer to German interest rates
because Greece was about to join the EU
and you can see what happened to Greek
debt relative to GDP back in the 70s it
was nothing then pop andreas father
Andreas Papandreou started borrowing a
lot of money and and the debt went way
up to 98 percent of GDP and then of
course recently it's gone way up and now
it's up at a hundred that's top line one
hundred eighty percent of GDP so it's
the government doing the borrowing if
you look at the household sector or the
corporate sector they're still not
borrowing it was very different from
other countries like Spain or you know
Ireland or places like that there was
the consumer borrowing I don't have time
to talk about their problems but was
very similar to the American problems in
Greece it was the government that
borrowed so they got bailed out now
where did the money go initially that
bailed them out someone asked a great
question why didn't they just let Greece
default right at the beginning of the
crisis maybe forgive everything and let
Greece go on its way that might have
been the best thing to do but Greece
didn't default instead they got bailed
out so what did that mean
bailed-out it mean they were given the
money to pay back the previous debt and
so who got paid back well if you look at
all the the foreign banks that owed
money held Greek debt you look at every
year how much Greek debt they had well
when the crisis started and the bailout
started it all got paid off so all those
banks got bailed they got paid off the
Greeks paid them back so part of the
bailout terms was what was called
austerity they had to take their 15%
deficit and cut it down to zero they had
to start running a surplus so look what
happened to their government spending it
fell by 30 percent
an astounding fall no country has
reduced government spending that
dramatically that fast and so why why
did the the troika think that this was a
good thing to do well they all predicted
each year they would say look you take
this dose of medicine you cut everything
you balance your budget of course things
are gonna get worse for a year or two
but they're not gonna turn around when
the world sees that you've done that and
everything's gonna get much better so
here you see the predictions the IMF
made each year starting whatever in 2009
say so they'd already start at some
number things they'd say well the next
year they're gonna get bad but then
they'll start going better okay so they
did get bad then they starting from that
same point I've normalized that to
always start at the same point they made
another prediction you'll things got
worse than they expected even the first
year they made another prediction of
things getting bad and turning around
things got even worse so the next year
they make another prediction they kept
predicting lower and lower and lower
every year they make the they'd always
think it would turn around and each time
they had to make lower predictions so it
was almost catastrophic if you look at
the change in in a Greek output it's you
know it's negative starting 2008 or 2009
this is a very telling graph you look
starting in 2008 at every country what
was their percentage growth in GDP
starting in 2007 so at the top is
Australia there's Canada there's the US
this is up to 2014 a lot of countries
are growing not brilliantly you know the
u.s. is only up like five percent and
seven years it's not great but they're
positive and a few of them are slightly
negative
the ones who borrow too much denmark and
things like that
italy's down eight or nine percent
there's grease down twenty five percent
just off the charts what happened to
greece okay there was greek unemployment
it went up to twenty five percent and
it's still twenty one percent now today
you look at the recession the change in
output you compare the greek problem
with what happened in nineteen twenty
nine in the US the drop was bigger in
the US but it turned around after six or
seven years in greece it just went down
and stayed down it's still down so the
greek suffering and loss of output is
bigger than the loss in america
percentage of gdp in the great
depression okay you look at the
austerity greece had to run compared to
every other country and it's not so
surprising output went down so much more
because now they were spending way
beyond their means but to cut the 30%
cut in government spending it's almost
unheard of and it's quite surprising
that if you draw a straight line between
what countries had to cut there what
percentage of government spending they
cut and what was the loss in output it
fits pretty well on a straight line and
greece had the biggest cut and had the
biggest loss and output so in the greek
situations even worse then i'm
describing because this debt of a
hundred eighty percent it sold entirely
to foreigners the americans who owed 130
percent 120 percent after the war the
great generation owed it to themselves
there was all american bondholders not
german bondholders so the greeks have to
pay all the money outside the the debt
in euros is much worse than it looks
because greek wages and prices keep
falling and falling and following it's
not their own currency so actually in
terms of wage ours is getting bigger and
bigger and finally the banking system
that's their Achilles heel which i'm
going to talk about in a minute his
company is in dire straits so of the two
hundred forty billion euros that they
had a hundred twenty billion left so
they just disappeared so how did they
get paid off obviously this is the bank
run story that I told you other people
tell how could they I'm Greece didn't
the money the banks didn't have the
money to pay them so what happened is
the ECB loan Greece the money to make up
for all these deposits so half their
money is now being loaned they're being
propped up by loans from the ECB so
Greece is really entirely dependent on
the ECB oh the loans that Greece has
half of them are non-performing so
they've lost half their depositors half
the loans they have or non-performing
which means they're not getting any
money in which means they can't real own
any money so what could they do and now
this is the last thing I'm gonna say
before I talk about what my plan was
it's very hard to start an economy going
when the banks can't lend any money now
one of the few ways they might get their
hands on some money is if they sold off
their non-performing loans you know
their loans were supposedly for a
hundred maybe they're only worth fifty
that's what they're marked at so why not
sell them off for 50 well there really
couldn't find any buyers at more than 30
the point is that it always happens in
Italy in Greece in all these countries
the people the banks that have
non-performing loans don't want to give
them up and that's why they can't get
their hands on any new money to lend out
and why don't they want to give them up
there are two reasons one is they're
probably marked higher than they should
be even though it's the ECB marking them
they're probably marked higher than they
should be but a second more subtle
reason is that these loans were
collateralized their I mean their
businesses collateralizing them there
are no other businesses that they can
use for collateral so these are the best
loans that they have they can't find any
other loans they can't bet on anything
else turning around so the banks are
pretty the people who are bankers almost
always pretty optimistic so this is the
best bet that they have they don't want
to give up the loans and if they sell
them to someone more risk-averse they're
gonna get a lot less money than the
bankers think they're worth that is the
crucial problem in all these countries
with the non-performing loans there's a
late last available collateral and the
bankers don't want to give them up so
they're stuck holding them and they've
got no new money to give to anyone else
so it's sort of a doomed triangle the
banks held a huge amount of Greek bonds
so in the Greek bonds
started to go bad they started to lose
money so that means they and they have
these non-performing loans with an
entrepreneur's they can't loan to new
entrepreneurs the new entrepreneurs
can't do anything business is so bad
they're not paying any taxes so the
government's not getting any money so
they can't pay their bonds with the
Greek banks that hold the bonds are
losing more money so it just goes around
and around and around and it can't stop
so what should we do about it so the IMF
spent a lot of time thinking about this
as I said I think they made quite a few
mistakes maybe it wasn't easy to predict
what was gonna happen
they play a very funny role I think
they're very great people some of them
the number 2% the IMF was another
classmate of mine
I saw taka Toshi Ito who was next to
arrow who's rescued the Japanese social
security system by getting them to
invest in a American stocks you got you
had David Lipton is the number two
person at the IMF Larry Summers was the
secretary of the Treasury Ben Bernanke
was them mit in same year I was so we
saw each other all the time all these
people seemed to have done quite well
for themselves so anyway so I think the
IMF has a lot of very capable people but
they seem to play a similar role a
country goes badly they come in they
impose austerity and then they try to
get things turned around and sometimes
they do and sometimes they don't
so after ruining helping to ruin the
Greek economy I think even they would
realize they've made a mistake they've
now become the good guys so they're
saying so what was the deal that Greeks
signed okay I forgot to say this so when
varoufakis caused remember what happened
with verify because he was the guy who
rode a motorcycle in a black leather
jacket and showed up to meet all the
finance ministers of Europe dressed like
that even though they are all in their
suits and ties and told the Germans they
were Nazis who owed Greece money rather
than Greece
their money and then he said that Greece
was going to just drop out of the euro
and so they had a vote in Greece the
yes/no vote should Greece accept the
terms of the troika or should they
rejected and 65% voted to reject and so
Varro fichus went back and he said you
see our people have rejected it and so
the German said well if you reject the
terms then you're on your own and so
then he went and he tried the head of
these conversations they tried to find
out how long it would take to print
drachmas and it turns out it's eight
months to start printing drachmas again
and so they went back and they said well
we're actually not going to you leave
the Euro but you're gonna make the terms
better we presume because we've rejected
them and the Germans said no we're gonna
make the terms worse because you
rejected them so the terms became Greece
has to pay three and a half percent of
GDP for about 30 years three and a half
percent now remember the u.s. the
greatest generation only twice managed
to pay three and a half percent of GDP
and Greece is supposed to do it for 20
or 30 years that was the terms and
remember that the debt is all old to
external people not like the American
debt to internal people and remember
that Greece hadn't yet to pay a single
drachma bat single euro back to they
hadn't paid anything back they weren't
running a surplus so they're supposed to
go from paying nothing back all the time
all during this crisis Germany and
Europe was lending Greece money to pay
themselves back Greece wasn't actually
paying anything the austerity didn't
come from the fact that Greece was
paying out so much money it came from
the fact that a head couldn't run a
deficit anymore it had to change
convulsively change so fast so it's
hopeless Greece is never gonna be able
to pay three-and-a-half percent of GDP
for 30 years no country could do that so
why doesn't why don't the Europeans just
I mean they're very sophisticated
why don't they realize that and forgive
some of the debt so I think you have to
look at it from their point of view
they're not crazy so what are some of
the problems well the first problem is
the
the debts owed to a lot of people like
to the ECB the central bank the central
bank has marked it at a hundred remember
so if Greece says we're not gonna pay
back our debt and they own rique bonds
and things like that they have to
suddenly take a loss so a loss that they
haven't taken before just like with the
banks in America so that would mean that
Angela Merkel would have to go to the
German people and say well we have to
refund the Greek the central bank
because we've forgiven Greek debt
so let's increase taxes is a very
difficult thing for her to do now
another thing is Greece can't borrow
nobody's gonna lend to Greece now it's
almost impossible they borrowed a few
billion euros or something four months
ago but they it's almost impossible to
borrow why can't they borrow because
they all so much no one thinks that they
can get repaid so of course they can't
borrow well Europe loves that they don't
want to see Greece get into more trouble
and have to be bailed out again if
you're a German you're thinking my gosh
we've poured all this money into Greece
bailing them out we just better make
sure this is the last time we bail them
out so actually they're feeling pretty
good that they don't have to lend you
know they don't have to get let Greece
into another problem like that now if
you forgive Greek debt you have to think
about forgiving other people's debt and
and so it's very very difficult to that
mean there's Italy that's you know we
have two huge problems in Spain that
have huge problems aren't they gonna ask
for their debt to be forgiven and
finally one of the most important
reasons is that Greece is still getting
money Germany is lending Greece more and
more money you know to pay them you know
to pay the IMF back to pay private
creditors back as well that Greece
Greece actually defaulted on half the
private creditors but there's still the
other have to pay that the Greeks can't
pay the Germans are lending the money to
pay that stuff off there are all these
hospitals they're going under and
there's you know the workers haven't
been paid and the doctors haven't been
paid Greece is lending the money to make
up for that to pay the arrears so
Germany has to lend more money how do
you go to the German public and say you
know the Greeks can't pay the debt so
we're forgiving it and by the way we're
gonna lend them more money that they're
not gonna be able to pay it's a very
difficult sell so put yourself in the
German spot it's
so easy for them to forgive Greek debt
so it's not so maybe they could have
done it at the very beginning by the way
well you know the Greek banks will
totally go under if Greece leaves the
euro now so it's not so simple to
forgive the debt so there was a standoff
between the eyes of the so the Germans
wanted to you know keep the process
going and the IMF finally spoke up and
said no this is too much you're asking
cut the three and a half percent to one
and a half percent otherwise we won't
bless the plan going forward and then
you're on your own now the German this
no Europeans want to be on their own
they want to say it's all the IMF
telling us this is what we should do
it's not our fault we're not you know
hurting Greeks or other Europeans we're
doing with the IMF says so they want the
IMF there and the IMF is saying no one
and a half percent that's all they can
pay so there's the standoff and that's
when I show up so I had a freshman
roommate Jane Jeremy Bulow who also
became very famous and now he's of
Stanford professor and I decided to put
a committee together which ended up just
being the two of us to do the Greek debt
thing and so this is our joint proposal
so the that the you know the the Germans
of Europe is saying you got to stick to
the deal it was three and a half percent
the IMF saying reduce it to one and a
half percent neither one will move so
why our first proposal is make how much
and every year what happens Greece can't
make the one and a half percent were the
three and a half percent and then they
have to say okay you didn't make it this
year will lend you some more money and
starting next year in 2018 now you have
to make it's gonna be one and a half
percent and three-quarters percent in
the next year three and a half percent
starting then it's three and a half
percent but every year Greece doesn't
pay anything back and they have to
renegotiate it's a huge waste of time
incredibly time-consuming irritating to
everybody so our first plan proposal is
index what Greece pays to how the
economy is doing if it's doing
incredibly badly like now it shouldn't
have to pay very much and as the economy
gets better the number can go up so what
was our indexing formula Greek the Greek
economy is 100
eighty billion the government's half
that ninety billion we said make Greece
pay seven percent of 90 billion - sixty
billion now it sounds a little
complicated but this is how you get it
graduated a progressive taxes by you you
know it's like the negative income tax
you offset it's not 70 percent of G but
70 percent of G minus 60 so the first
year is 70 percent of 30 which is 1.2
percent of GDP probably pretty hard for
them to pay but we didn't have the nerve
to ask for less so 1.2 percent of GDP as
G grows that percentage grows and if G
is always half of GDP G's government
spending if it's half of GDP and grows
off to infinity the 60s irrelevant and
7% of half of GDP is three and a half
percent so eventually it's three and a
half percent if Greece's economy
miraculously recovers but it starts at
one point - you don't have to keep
negotiating if things are bad they'll
have to pay 1.2 again if they get even
worse they'll pay less than 1.2 so that
way you you make it sensible it depends
on how the economy is going you don't
have to renegotiate now the trouble with
that is that goes on indefinitely I mean
there's no end to that so since it
requires 3 and a half percent for 30
years to repay the debt paying starting
at one point two percent you know maybe
going up a little bit that's not going
to repay all the debt so Greece is gonna
be in terrible debt to infinity it's it
feels awful to be in debt if you've ever
been in debt to be in debt that you can
never repay it's a crushing feeling
business is never gonna start up if
Greece has no prospect of ever paying
off the debt like the three and a half
percent in perpetuity
so our second plan now we have to make a
plan where we meet the German and
European needs to have everything happen
slowly and so they don't suddenly
forgive all the Greek debt we have to
make the Greeks think that the debts
been forgiven right away because once
the debts been forgiven right away the
Greeks will try to pay off the part of
it they'll pick deal 2/3 of it say
they'll try to pay off the last third
before two thirds of it's forgiven
they're not realized I've gone way over
this will just be one more
at the punchline so how can you so
forgiving debt is actually good for the
Germans in a way because if you forgive
two-thirds of the Greek debt they'll say
to themselves almost one-third we can
pay that off we'll start paying it if
there's such a huge amount that they owe
that they can never pay it off why
should they pay any of it
why pay taxes if you know your tax money
is going to pay a debt that's still
going to be infinite it's not that the
Greeks are so crazy and so dishonest
that they're so reluctant to pay taxes
the money is going to pay a debt that
can never be paid off you cut that down
you'll get a lot more people willing to
pay taxes so but you have to make the
Germans think you haven't forgiven it
right away so how can you have the
Greeks think it's forgiven and the
Germans thinks you know okay so our
second plan was every time Greece pays
back a euro you count it as three so the
Greeks are gonna say to themselves well
we only have to pay a third of the debt
because they forgiven two thirds of it I
mean we'll have to pay a third and the
other two you know it's counted as three
the Greeks will immediately think two
thirds of the debts forgiven they'll act
as if two thirds of it is forgiven
they'll start trying to pay as fast as
they can
what will the Germans think they'll
think what the Greeks haven't paid us
anything yet how long is it going to
take them to pay us back they're still
tremendously in debt maybe they pay you
know few billion euros this year okay we
have to count a triple that's not like
200 billion euros that we have to
forgive and you know bailout the ECB and
raise huge amounts of money is 10 or 20
billion euros that's not going to ruffle
so many feathers we can do that
meanwhile the Greek debt is still
incredibly high they can't borrow again
so the Germans are gonna think okay
eventually we may have to forgive the
debt but for a long time the debts still
hanging over them if they don't do what
they're supposed to do the plan gets
cancelled and then the debts still there
so Germany maintains all the leverage
and power over Greece because the debt
is still there and if the Greeks grew up
then the you know the plan gets
cancelled but the Greeks are gonna act
as if it was forgiven right away so that
was the plan
so I went to the IMF and to the you know
and tried to sell the plan
went to euclid tsakalotos and tried to
sell the plan and he said why like that
forgiveness but I don't you you can't
say that we're not capable of paying I
said what do you mean I can't say that
you're not capable of paying you're not
capable of paying and and he said we
promised the Germans we could pay we
went back and we said yes we will pay
what we have to do is convince them that
we've we've accepted their terms we've
kept our word and now that we've kept
our word they're gonna see we're
virtuous and deserve forgiveness and
they're gonna forgive us we can't say we
can't pay and therefore you should
forgive us so I went to the IMF and I
said well you know what do you think of
a plan and they said well anything that
gets the debt lower we're in favor of if
you get Sokolow just to say this is what
they want to do then you know we can
work we'll see if we can work something
out but he wouldn't do it and and maybe
it's a crazy plan but that was the plan
so I end with that thought that it's the
leverage cycle that's caused a lot of
our problems and the end of the leverage
cycle is too much debt that can't be
paid and the only way out is to
recognize that it's better to forgive
sometimes you have to be clever about
how you forgive but you have to forgive
thank you
okay I've taken almost all the time but
if anyone wants to ask a question I'm
happy to try an answer last night last
night you talked about the people of
Venice
and when Shylock lost his money because
he didn't get paid back surely that
would have had a cascading effect
because Shylock was an optimist and a
developer and he had borrowed money in
the promise of getting returned from the
people he had loan to my question is
what are the particular indicators in
the financial world that you watch to
see that might be triggering events the
the financial butterflies that cause
okay so I'll repeat your question very
good question
so Shylock actually didn't have the
3,000 ducats to lend Antonio and
Bassanio he borrowed them from his
friend too long so that meant that there
could be a cascading series of defaults
if Shylock doesn't get paid back to ball
doesn't get paid back and who knows who
to ball borrowed the money from so the
question I think was if you're
advocating forgiveness don't you have to
be careful that you might be starting
some terrible cascade that's gonna have
a huge effect so the hope so my answer
is the whole point of my forgiveness is
to do it in cases where you're gonna get
more money back not less money back so
the idea was to ask these community
bankers change the terms write down the
principle if you think that's the best
way to get money back by reducing the
amount owed you can often get more money
back they're not gonna get any money
back from Greece if somehow things by
one charade or another aren't partly
forgiven
the only way that the Germans are gonna
get repaid is by making the Greeks
understand that they don't have to hit
180 billion euros which they can't pay
back so in the subprime case we don't
have so this is partly conjecture on my
part but in the subprime case we have
data remember I'll repeat my story the
people who got thrown out of their
houses when they were told they're being
thrown in other houses they got very
uncooperative so they didn't do anything
to help the lenders not surprisingly so
and they got to stay in their house for
a couple years before the courts moved
and so the average recovery out of a
hundred sixty thousand was thirty five
or forty thousand a terrible recovery if
you could forgive 160 down to 90 and
potentially get more back you're not
gonna start a cascade now the Obama
administration made a mistake I think
because someone else suggested it a lot
of people were saying let's forgive all
the debt let's forgive huge swathes of
debt if you forgave huge swathes of debt
Fannie and Freddie debt for example and
you suddenly the banks had to mark their
positions down the banks would lose a
lot of money maybe they'd go underwater
and that would start a cascading effect
that's the kind of thing you're thinking
of but you see the subprime loans worse
so now why is this the case because if a
bank makes a loan if I'm a banker and I
lend you the money and you're still
paying I can count it as a hundred I
don't have to market to market if I'm a
hedge if I'm now I'm where my other hat
is a hedge fund I say that subprime
borrower is 60 percent underwater he may
have paid the last few months but he's
gonna default sooner or later so I say
his loan is only worth 50 you know
probably we'll get 23 out of it not a
hundred but the bank could still counted
us a hundred so they don't have to mark
to market so the banks maybe would have
to take these big losses and that's and
the Obama administration you see the
people the people in power who have the
view that it's all confidence you just
restore confidence you can restore the
economy that's a bank centric view
because that means you don't want the
banks to go under so everything you do
should be to help the banks stay afloat
so you want to keep the banks afloat you
don't want to keep Main Street afloat so
the banks who held subprime mortgages
they were securitized then by law they
had to mark them to market a loan they
don't have to mark to market but if it's
a securitized you know market traded
thing they can't lie about what the
market price is so those they had to
March a market so my claim is that the
market price which is determined by
these hedge funds when things started to
get forgiven would have gone up not down
so it wouldn't have started a cascade
with the banks suddenly having to mark
things down and going under and then the
next Bank going under and so on I think
it's a very good question but that's the
whole point of a plan it was to start
forgiving people who hadn't defaulted
yet so it's not a moral hazard whose
house values went down there underwater
which was that also beyond their control
and for things that were securitized and
already marked to market precisely to
prevent your cascade and not to cause a
moral hazard yes absolutely we should
have been doing that well we should have
been okay so people so I'm advocating
when leverage is going way up and you
see the price of the thing that's being
leveraged go way up that's a sign to me
when that's you when the credit surface
gets very flat and the collateral price
goes very quickly up that's the sign to
me that credit conditions have gotten
too loose and the Fed should stand in
and not just say we're changing the
interest rate it should say like the
Bank of Israel you may know that Stan
Fisher was the number-two guy in the Fed
under Janet Yellen he was the head of
the Bank of Israel during the crisis and
he said housing prices are going up too
fast this Bank of Israel declares that
no bank can lend at more than 60% LTV on
a house so that's what I'm advocating
and we don't do that our Fed has never
done that it has the power to do that
but has never done that now you can see
how that's politically
very difficult to do because there are a
lot of people who can't buy houses
because they don't have the cash and
they're not gonna they're gonna be upset
but that's what I'm advocating yes you
may have just answered my question but I
you were talking about credit services
and you were talking about
there's the commercial credit surface
and then there's sort of the housing
market credit surface and the consumer
loan right and you were saying well
let's suppose that one credit surface
you were pointing on I think it was the
housing surface was different than the
commercial loo right that was and you
were saying therefore the Fed should do
something to affect this the credit
surface that was was poor and I was just
wondering what suggestions you'd had for
it for say correcting the housing
surface okay that's a very good question
so I was so let me make my point again
but I didn't quite go as far as you said
I said they're these the Fed just seems
to change the interest rate that's all
anybody knows about if you read in the
newspapers is the Fed changing the
interest rate but that those changes
it's making are affecting these three
credit surfaces in interesting ways
so my first claim was that the Fed
should gather it so much easier for them
to get the data than it is for me to get
the data actually this credit surface
was drawn with the help of the Board of
Governors at the Washington Fed but you
know I should step away and let them do
it all they should produce this every
three months that was my first
suggestion my second suggestion is when
they have their conversations they
should be talking in terms of what
effect they're gonna have on the credit
surfaces and which ones they want to
affect then we'll know whether they
really know what they're doing and
they'll know what they're trying to do
and then my most daring recommendations
I didn't quite make but I actually
probably did make it meant not to but I
actually believe that they should try
and directly go in and affect credit
services that they want to so how could
you do this well they did it during the
crisis what happened in the crisis is
that the student loan market collapsed
because nobody was willing to buy the
student loan securities the car lending
market collapsed because no one is
willing to buy the car
loans all these markets were collapsing
the Fed realized that the whole economy
was going to go under so what they did
was called peep hip in another program
tell so what they did is they went and
they said if you want to buy a housing
securitization will lend you 95 percent
of the value even though the credit
service was such that the market was
longing to lend them 60% of the value
will lend at a higher LTV than the
market will lend and that's the way they
could increase leverage if they wanted
to the way they could decrease leverages
do what Stan Fischer said you just can't
loan it higher than 60% LTV one more
question so there were two things that I
didn't hear you address in talking about
the mortgage crisis one was the
development of interest only when there
was predominant in the subprime the
other is the fact that forgiveness of
debt is a taxable event to the person
for to whom the debt is forgiven and
it's treated as ordinary income by the
IRS yes well okay so there was a taxable
income and the first one was the Excel
was your first question
Oh interest only okay so one of the
interesting things that happen in the
crisis is that the mortgages started
getting more and more complicated so
they were interest only there are
negative amortized loans through a whole
series of loans like that so interest
only means instead of paying you pay
less basically at the beginning and
eventually you're gonna have to pay more
so and negative amortized means you
might not pay anything at the beginning
and eventually the principal is going to
go up and so you'll eventually have to
pay down a higher principle now it turns
out that those loans all defaulted more
than the more conventional loans but you
know you could say that each of those
loans is a surreptitious way of adding a
higher LTV because if you're not paying
anything for three years and so the
principal the amount you should have
paid gets added to the principal every
year the principal started in a hundred
and you know it's gonna go to one
hundred seven 114 and so really if you
look out just a couple years it's a much
higher loan than it was at the beginning
so I so I think your point is Oh guess
what your point is your point is that
these kinds of loans fit your story of
high LTV but they don't fit exactly into
your credit surface because you have to
do a calculation now you just can't look
at the terms of the loan how much is
borrowed and figure out what the correct
LTV is you have to take into account the
structure of the loan and therefore do a
more sophisticated thing to get a
meaningful LTV and so is your credit
surface really that useful I think that
might have been your question so well
anyway let's ask that question so so yes
I think that you do have to do that and
it gets a little bit more complicated
and I think that that's part of the
reason why the Federal Reserve you know
the New York Federal Reserve is also
working on these credit services and I
think that's why it got them a little
bit bogged down because not everything
is a is a constant interest rate
mortgage they're floating interest rate
mortgages they start at a lower interest
rate and so you how can you put them on
the same picture so there's a way that
economists deal with this thing is
called option adjusted spread so you try
and figure out by doing various
calculation what effectively is the is
the interest rate at which you ought to
value all those securities and so I
would substitute some complicated
computation like that for the actual
interest rate given in the terms of the
mortgage so it's going to take a little
bit of work before these credit services
become usable but I think even just
using the data that we have now they're
usable by over these IO loans interest
only loans they're much fewer than now
than there were before we're back to an
older era with much simpler mortgages
where these credit services are easier
to do now your question about the taxes
I forgot the answer to that I worried
about that but even if there are taxes
involved you know if the go
weren't playing a role I think that
could I don't think that's a that's the
reason why Susan cognac the lawyer was
involved in this and now I can't good
question which I don't remember the
answer to but there so the danger is
that they'll suddenly have to pay a huge
amount of tax in the first year and then
how are they going to do that and so
it's actually going to hurt them to
forgive the loan and not make them
better off but there's a way there's a
legal way around that thank you very
much